you've said that
if you do cyber crime eventually it's
not going to end well it does not end
well why is that
so i don't want to say that's because
you're going to be arrested because
honestly very few people are arrested
all right
but it doesn't end well because of the
type of person that that you become
you you quoted me earlier you you lie
to everybody around you you lie to
yourself you lie to your friends you
like your family of course you lie to
your victims
you don't have any friends
you know i went 20 years
without friends i had associates i
didn't have friends um you can't truly
trust you don't trust anybody you don't
trust anybody you know i had uh
my wife i was married for nine years
i lied to her every single day of those
nine years
and it took her nine years to uh
to give up on me to realize that i was
that piece of [ __ ]
and
she leaves at that point
then from there i started dating a
stripper and lied to her i thought i had
friends i lied to all those people that
i knew that thought they were my friends
i lied to him the entire time you become
that individual
i don't think a lot of people really
understand
how bad that is you know you talked
about you pointed out that woman
that i ripped off she was trying to put
a a roof on her house for freaking kids
man you're that person you're that
person so you're also lying to yourself
and that's not a mindset in which you
can
grow as a person
find happiness find genuine simple human
affection which is what love is yeah
simple real friendship all of those
things right so you know i went to
prison of course
one of the things that one of the most
important lessons i that i've learned in
prison
because cyber crime as a whole if you're
a criminal it's an addiction all right
if you're addicted to something whether
it be drugs crime gambling what have you
if you're addicted to something you
cannot
love anything else except the addiction
the addiction comes first
all right and you know you pointed out
some of those
truly despicable things
script for example tortures that guy
you get to the point where it's like
okay
this is the business
and you know i tried to convince myself
that uh
you know i'm a businessman but i'm a
good guy on the other end and you're not
you're not so those lies become
part of it everything else and uh
you know it's yeah you get the higher
ups are usually arrested they are but
you know you've got millions of cyber
criminals these days so most guys are
not going to be arrested
so you may be arrested you may um
you may be like
freaking jonathan james he was a minor a
very very talented individual
very competent
he had
as a kid he had broke into nasa dod
pentagon he shut the nasa computers down
for six weeks this is like that kid uh
then he decides he wants to go into
credit card theft partners with albert
he's arrested with albert um
law enforcement
they were going on they were going to
blame him he was the only competent
individual
so this kid gets up one day he wasn't in
prison yet he gets up one day goes in
his dad's bedroom gets out as 45
walks in the bathroom and blows his
brains out
you know you've got you've got things
like that um
or you're gonna rip somebody off and
you're gonna end up like scripted with
that guy the uh
the guy who hit uh who ran evolution
marketplace no one knew who two people
ran that guy and girl
and no wonder who they were
he ends up stealing about 24 million
dollars a lot of from ukrainian mob and
they found him about a year later on a
beach without his head and hands
but uh you know it always goes south but
more than anything to me the uh
the negative thing is is you really
become somebody
that i mean just truly a despicable
human being when you get to the point
when you're you're still you're you're
destroying people's retirement accounts
you're stealing money from a woman that
simply wants to do
something good for her family
when you when you become that individual
and you're okay with that my god man i
got to the point i had one guy ripped
off
it's like for nine hundred dollars is
when i first started the cyber crime
stuff that's when i was becoming
competent
and
i ripped them off for like 900
and he sent me an email
and uh
he was like uh i the email said
something like uh
i guess you needed the money
and it's okay
you know you keep it and uh
i'm getting chills right now thinking
about it but it's that uh
where you become that individual
you